herr sensburg dieser ganze flaggen
streiten was sagen sie dazu hätte berlin
sich da tatsächlich anders verhalten
müssen ich glaube man kann sich sehr
viel deutlicher verhalten ich glaube die
fronten sind klar dass russland hier
einen angriffskrieg führt aber ich will
mich jetzt nicht in die berliner
landespolitik oder die bundespolitik
einmischen wir gucken ja auch das
militärische und auf die rede auch von
wladimir putin damals noch einmal ganz
kurz reingehen weil wir mögen das
militärische reden jetzt fängt nämlich
ein die eigentlich militär parade an und
sehen wir nämlich einen weltkriegs
panzer den berühmten tief 34 der überall
in russland in jedem dorf eingang steht
und da sehen wir eine symbolik und die
werde ich mir putin auch erst geschaffen
weil also natürlich die sowjetischen
fahne dran aber nun auf dem geschützturm
sehen wir auch an geklebt oder
aufgehängt die das georgs band geox
fahne das ist es schwarz orange symbol
das la die mir putin aus der zarenzeit
wieder ausgegraben
hat wer dran und wir sehen übrigens kein
set heute sondern wir sehen immer nur
das sowohl georgs band was sagt uns dass
wir sensburg sie sind cdu-politiker aber
natürlich auch chef des
reservistenverbandes stramm in der
uniform heute was sagt uns das wir sehen
dass wir aufs band ja auch schon lange
zeit auch in der bevölkerung als klares
zeichen der unterstützung der russischen
truppen gesehen dass zb an den
rückspiegeln an den autos als klares
zeichen dass man die soldatinnen und
soldaten unterstützt es ist also im
grunde ein historischer schluss vom
vaterländischen krieg von großen
vaterländischen krieg bis heute in das
was die väter angefangen hat will man
fortsetzen kampf gegen rassismus und das
ist natürlich etwas was nicht trägt es
ist ein irrsinn zu bezeichnen in der
ukraine das wäre nazis der westen
unterstützt ein nazi geblieben aber das
versucht ihn auch in seiner rede auf die
er nicht so wie erwartet war in lichten
und general mobil machen oder in
richtung kriegserklärung ist man eher
den schulterschluss mit den vätern mit
den großeltern die heutige zeit 2012
schluss in die verschiedenen
volksgruppen hinein das ist der versuch
und das versucht man einerseits in der
symbolik auf den alle panzern aber auch
wir sind eben die neuen der eine
geschlossene linie zu zeigen aber ich
glaube wir werden auch das z heute noch
sehen aber ganz gut kann ist er
tatsächlich sein dass putin mit dieser
defensiv rede nenne ich sie jetzt mal
die welt auch ein bisschen in die irre
führen will einfach neuen
überraschungsmoment schaffen also ich
gehe davon aus dass es eine klare
propaganda rede einerseits nach innen
ist die geschlossenheit der nation
herbeizuführen die menschen bekommen ja
auch mit dass diese spezialoperation
länger dauert das inzwischen jedes dorf
jeder ort betroffen ist das junge
soldatinnen und soldaten eingezogen
werden kämpfen müssen aber auch fallen
das lässt sich schwer erklären deswegen
dieser schulterschluss aber es zeigt
eben auch dass putin die karten nicht
offenlegen will eine generalmobilmachung
war nicht zu erwarten das habe ich sehr
frühzeitig gesagt das hätte bedeutet
dass alle die im wehrfähigen alter sind
bemustert werden dass wir reservisten
alle einberufen das ist einfach so gar
nicht möglich einen krieg zu erklären
während man die ganze zeit eine
spezialoperation redet war auch nicht zu
erwarten ist der schulterschluss die
erklärung dass es länger dauert und den
besten möglicherweise in der sicherheit
wegen das ist hier doch zufrieden kommen
kann russischer seite aus wird es nicht
zufrieden kommen wird er dazu führen
dass die ukraine weiter kämpfen und
russland aus meiner sicht auf dauer
grimm und die östlichen gebiete
verlieren wird das müssen wir festhalten
sie gehen davon aus wladimir putin wird
nicht nur diesen krieg nicht so gewinnen
wir eben gewinnen wollte sondern er wird
auch das verlieren was er sich 2014 holt
krim und don was haben das von anfang an
gesagt nur viele militärexperten gesagt
haben nach wenigen tagen ist hier
ausgefallen und es wird eine vasallen
regierung eingesetzt das ist von der
größe des landes her überhaupt nicht
möglich der ganze vormarsch in die
fläche des landes ist gestoppt ist
zurückgedrängt worden es geht jetzt noch
um bestimmte gebiete die die erzählung
die legende von putin aufrechterhalten
sollen auch das wird er auf dauernde
schaffen er versucht immer wieder neuen
druck neu soldatin soldat der rat zu
führen auch das wird ihm auf dauer nicht
gelingen erkannt bäume nicht halten mit
dem was er dort auch bieten kann er kann
flächen baum herum ausmachen er kann
städte in schutt und asche legen er kann
weit über das land bringen aber wird es
auf dauer nicht halten können und er
wird im grunde verlieren und die frage
aus meiner sicht ist wann schaffen es
andere politische kräfte in russland ein
ende mit gut ihn zu machen eine zukunft
mit reiniger putin ist für russland
nicht möglich und das ist auch sehr
traurig für russland dass es in diese
schwere lage bekommt